[Music]
what's up guys to meet you here from the
score eSports now I think we can all
agree that league of legends is a
reasonably well balanced game the
problem is that sometimes despite riots
best efforts things have been known to
fall through the cracks over the years
we've seen broken champions busted items
and strats that have made the game
boring to watch and play so we thought
it would be fun to put on some
rose-colored glasses take a trip down
memory lane and remember those times
when the game's meta was at its worst
without further ado here are the top 10
worst metas in the history of League of
Legends kicking off our list is the item
that brought ap as reeled back into the
meta rune glaive that is it Hootie
Hoonie is face down Venera look at the
damage he's got another one seven one
seven and he's flying away introduced in
patch 5.2 elv rune glaive was riots
attempt to give ap jungle champions some
desperately needed buffs but it wasn't
long before players started to
experiment with it on non jungle
champions 35 minutes on the hives as
well as the coin chain well he's already
down this millions on the inhibitor
turret down part of a test is looking to
get through the gate kickers gets hot
mystic shot sniped tabs down Jewish
operons
flies across the elements rust and
unicorns of love look for one more a
little bit of a whoopsie from Hiller sag
already a high damage carry Ezreal
became laughably broken with rune glaive
Sandman is sustained and Auto Attack
modifier allowing him to spam abilities
and deal ludicrous amounts of damage at
a very low cost ship this down he was
tried for the one-shot but he missed him
flash away from York said just cost
himself and life wild growth goes out
boomerang goes across trueshot barrage
for the finish so many things that can
come across to kill you ninja Goes Down
smoothie Goes Down and like you said jad
I was only gonna take one good fight TSM
could have that Nexus and six months
after its release rune glaive was
removed from the game entirely taking
the number 9 spot in our list is the
season for meta that saw the rise of duo
jungling because of the prominence of
lane swaps top laners were vulnerable in
the early game which led to the rise of
duo jungler to get a little mirror to
ring-around-the-rosie through buffs
yep gonna happen duo jungles top laners
go ahead and jungle except that you
don't get any jungle items good luck
Adventure and this is the kind of new
contention lanes we're seeing in
competitive league the to be zero
with many roamers there are a ton of
strategic possibilities with this
because the only people really
constraint two lanes is the ad carry in
the mid laners the supports are free to
roam the Junkers are further up and the
top laners are free to roam so the
vision control becomes even more of a
priority one side effect of duo jungling
was the four-man tower push strategy
where the duo jungle would start on the
same side of the map as the bot lane duo
clear their jungle and then push down a
lane as a group of four with little to
no counter play teams were able to run
down tier 1 towers with zero opposition
three buffs dip to lay him a little bit
in terms of damage onto this turret but
the the bottom Tower is a bit softer of
poor luck but they didn't get the tower
and they're losing their tier 2 right
now so was that all in we'll see if it
was one good plan cost all season
it's really bad for frost and they're
gonna push the wave in yep yeah they are
Wow
all right na purists close your eyes and
ears because number eight on our list
might be a tough pill to swallow it's
the North American season one meta in
North American Pro play it was widely
accepted that the best formation was to
have a mage in the top lane an ADC solo
laning mid a tank in the jungle and a
bruiser and support duo in the bottom
Lane well at this point in time what
people it teams were doing is they were
just putting champions with a heavy
crowd control in bottom lane that tended
to be the thing that you'd see so for
example counter logics were ganas ion
Lane kind of is an example with teams to
do it's like okay well Saiyans got a
stun Morgana's got a binding they've got
a lot of crowd control and you put them
together so let's just stuff them
together in a duo Lane and that way
we'll be able to use those skills and
team fights later on to put it simply
the meta was inefficient it was better
to put the weak early game ad carry's
with supports so they could farm and get
gold and mages were better suited mid
because it was safer and they could roam
ores who lost you the Karthus wall will
they go for the attack his mama comes up
the middle
laying down the null zone for us in the
back the irelia ultimate have a great
range and now they're able to push them
way back to the turret by season 1
world's the best North American teams
had adopted this ADC meta but Europe had
been practicing it for a while and the
results showed me open to attack and
surely this is good game
against all authority are gonna go
straight in that Nexus is going to fall
and we will see an all european grand
final here for season 1
$100,000 and well against all authority
versus fanatics
coming in at number 7 we have the gold
funneling meta from patches eight point
nine two eight point eleven nerfs to
mana items crit items and buffs to
jungle experience gave birth to the
extremely linear meta to clean that up
and fill the iron ring with sneaky
invincible super touch Donna with vanity
goodbye cthis consisting of a Kerri
taking smite and playing in the mid lane
the strategy was simply to give set
carry all the farm and all the jungle
minions turning them into an
unachievable monster with the help of
three or even four supports ol tees are
coming up hiccup see game right well the
fourth card comes out look at this next
she's able to shut down what did but it
is that the cost of his own life now
once it turns it back around flashing
forward got the flood wall passive to
bring it back to life the text goes for
before he started by the week but
there's simply not enough damage it was
the a Quadra kill for perk to close out
the game to close out the week not only
was this painful to watch it was boring
for a lot of the pro players who were
being forced to now place support and a
lack of counter play made it painful to
play against please just change the god
feel netting sit outside don't need to
play broom again but yeah it's just so
boring
okay hear us out on this one we know
some of the old heads look at season two
with Rose tinted glasses but number six
on our list is the season to support
meta season 2 was a time before trinkets
and sight stones which was why warding
was generally an afterthought to every
role other than supports essentially
supports would buy gold generation items
like Philosopher's Stone and heart of
gold and then used the rest of their
gold exclusively on wards so supports
weren't getting much gold and they were
having to build the same items even get
any gold but then all that gold they do
get they have to spend on wards supports
would sometimes go entire games without
a single full item build this effect a
champion diversity where the only
champions being played were ones who
stayed effective late game without items
well and Sona is something that they
just key off of every game they can get
najin sword picks it almost every game
but so does psycho under Chris as well
so they kind of taken it away from them
and they're gonna take out Lulu for
chowster
so that is his I think third game in a
row now on to Lully week he being her
picked up there no items only wards
looking back supports really how to draw
at life warding any voted for the
cleaver he's gonna clear on these flash
did he gets exhausted it's the Levi's
mad life but they gotta turn it down
that's gonna be first button is baby
that picks it up what's a game and now
compass it seems as though riot is
always trying to fix the jungle which is
why the cinderhulk meta makes its way in
at number five on our list to give
jungle tanks more late-game viability
riot replaced juggernaut in favor of
cinderhulk the enchantment had a 25%
bonus health buff which gave users
scalability into the late game and a
passive that dealt damage in an area of
effect around the user dealing increased
damage as the combat went on LG is gonna
come down here I'm go ahead get them in
the choke he's hoping to flash it he
goes that hook me and miss slicing
Maelstrom goes in it's gonna lustboy
locked up as well as santoor in the
middle but the backline of damage
dealers is really able to do what they
need to do wiping out counter logic
gaming now from who's gonna be the next
the rocket misses double it does have to
quit for this but it's already been used
and he can't cleanse the debt
doublelift come on in Wright's defense
the buffs for 12 just a bit too well
they get around the choppers without hit
and righteous glory doesn't really get
horny ultimate if TSM can make it
through this they got it but Clarke died
is locking them down bjergsen on the
outside he gets walked in with the
position reverser how is TS I'm still
alive in this one they are doing
everything they can but cloud 9
door on that fight the 25% health bonus
turned out to be too much for the items
low price point and faster than ever
you were met with an unkillable jungler
who would shrug off any attacks and
slowly cook you with the items passive
this didn't help jungle diversity with
tankier champions being the only real
choices unless you enjoy losing all
right rek sai's jungle does get picked
up corpus another rek sai's for himself
continuing on these fighter junglers he
played sets once but given the option
doesn't go for it again right initially
nerfed some of the champions who
benefited the most from cinderhulk but
when this proved ineffective they hit
cinderhulk
with three nerfs over the span of six
months finally bringing peace and
balance to the jungle perfectly balanced
this whole thing should be coming in at
number four on our list is the ardent
sensor meta in an attempt to make it a
more viable support item riot buffed the
ardent sensor early in season 7 giving
it scaling attack speed and scaling on
hit healing well I'm becoming incredibly
familiar with gold generation in the
bottom Lane what's ahead we have double
target ad carry's double coin supports
and I'm just gonna assume that they've
got gold generation
runes as well on those supports to
really fund to the artists months later
riot came to the realization that entire
games being dictated by the bot lane
wasn't very healthy for the game and
nerfed ardent sensor look guys balancing
a game in alpha is hard so we're gonna
cut riot some slack on this one but we
have to include the preseason 1 meta on
our list that early in Leakes life there
really was no matter people played
whatever they wanted wherever they
wanted but technically a lack of meta
can still be considered meta putting
more and more hours into the game a
couple of broken champions emerged
Twisted Fate had a 40 second cooldown
Global teleport on his E and a global
slow on his alt Jax had the ability to
dodge everything in the game including
tower shots and even fountain laser
allister's alt gave him full magic
immunity 80 attack damage and 80 percent
damage reduction and his passive gave
him additional damage to towers with
only a small pool of champs to choose
from almost every game would be decided
by who was the best at one of these
champions it's worth noting than in his
current incarnation card master is an
Universal ban in competitive play TLDR
it sucked
picture this it's preseason 3 your ADC
is peacefully farming the lane and
everything feels right that is until you
get ganked by the enemy Jarvan while he
kills you with ease you think to
yourself hmm I should build some armor
but you're wrong because no amount of
armor could save you from the number 2
meta on our list the Black Cleaver meta
this meta shift arose when riot decided
it would be okay to buff the Black
Cleaver giving an armor penetration and
reduction seon brutalizer plus an
interesting unique passive that shreds
armor on all of your physical abilities
stacking up to a certain amount meaning
you could buy for black cleavers and
apply all the armor penetration and
reduction at once as a result everyone
bought it multiple times jumping in the
man drops coming cleave it too good too
good
Kyary too good too [ __ ] good [ __ ] you
too
one can only guess why riot nerfed the
Black Cleaver ten days later effectively
killing the League of black cleavers
taking the top spot of our list for the
worst League of Legends meta shift is
the juggernaut meta right before world's
2015 riot released an update that would
[ __ ] champion diversity and turn the
tournament into a repetitious affair
they released the juggernaut rework
which buffed Garen skarner Darius and
mordekaiser the jungle was low on
diversity with Elise rek'sai and gragas
being the only champion seen serious
play what coot
is doing is saying okay we Baddeley's
our jungle in order for him to have an
early game impact he needs a release or
he needs the wreck site that's the two
preferred picks for hojin due to a bug
partway through the tournament riot had
to disable Rocky's gangplank also got a
rework that made him a late-game beast
rush yep if a barrel explodes on
multiple people oh maybe a cat's korilla
does come on to snake chain though out
gangplank let's get his own them away
this is not a man fight for the flash
with the flush out may pose blue buff
runs out so obviously the pull-up
barrels but that was so close fair
enough
due to so many game-changing picks and
only three bands to work with pick and
ban would go the same way every single
time red side was forced to ban
mordekaiser gangplank and a jungler
while blue side was allowed to pick what
was left on the board champion diversity
was at an all-time low and blatantly
overpower champions were running rampant
and while riot did eventually deal with
it after worlds it was a disastrous
showing on the game's biggest stage
the pic and Darius cloud died at three
members alive well guys that's our list
be sure to LIKE our video subscribe to
our Channel and let us know in the
comments if there's any other League of
Legends relay to top tens you want to
see see you next time
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button
[Music]